all right we got a brand new hey babe
sal is in here but to replace sal we got
tt jerry who has been been in prison for
20 years just got off parole for the
first time in her life since 18 since
she was 18. she is my child's um
godmother she is a transgender uh inmate
that's a part of my ex-inmate that's a
part of my family she's a lovely
beautiful soul has stories for days like
literally one of the most amazing people
you'll ever get a chance to listen to i
truthfully truthfully truthfully mean
that the episode was fantastic um it's a
different spin on hey babe sal will be
back next week sal and i will be back
next week we've had a little bit of
scheduling conflicts but we are coming
back next week baby um and right now the
hey bay merch is finally out go to
salvocanocomedy.com and get that merch
right now it might be up at
christycomedy.com as well but for sure
it's up at salvocanocomedy.com
right now get that hey bay merch and you
could see us live on the road i will be
in norwalk connecticut at the wall
street theater this saturday april 16th
holy saturday then next weekend april
22nd in san juan puerto rico and april
29th in bethlehem pennsylvania sally
babes will be i believe april
23rd in tulsa and april 24th in oklahoma
city and may 13th in burlington and may
14th at the beacon theater in new york
city go to salvocanocomedy.com for tiki
wikis now please sit back buckle up and
enjoy tt
and me
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid
[Music]
[Music]
hey hey
guys
sal you look different oh thank you you
like my new look yeah what have you been
doing tell us your tell us your exercise
and diet soup because you look great
lately i've been in the diet you know i
was trying to get myself together you
know
and i always say i admire d.t jerry you
know and i really wanted to look like
her today how has um impractical joker's
been uh it's been going on great yeah
yeah it's been going great any fun
pranks
um yeah there's been a couple of them
yeah yeah kind of funny yeah well you've
been you've been exercising and eating
so well sal that you've turned yourself
a lot of weight you have i know
sal you've been eating so well that
you've turned yourself into a
transgender puerto rican woman
puerto rico of course that's not simple
that's not sal you silly monkeys you
silly monkeys it's uh
okay really rabbit silly rabbit tricks
are for kids it's uh tt jerry jerry
had a scheduling conflict sal's doing of
course uh his hit show and practical
jokers and practical jokey wokies and uh
so we got tt jerry to fill in uh for the
episode we got homeless pimp we have
vanitia we have uh we're doing it live
from chrissy chaos manor um which is uh
my other podcast uh christy chaos
podcast i got my family in the
background um let's explain to them who
tt jerry is in case they haven't well
that's what i was going to say i wanted
tt jerry to actually explain herself tt
jerry just in case there are a few fans
from the hey babe show that don't listen
to the christy chaos podcast and may not
know who you are which i think is insane
but i'm sure they do but let's just say
there's a few fans that don't who are
who is tt jerry who are you well
how you doing my fans out there my
peoples i'm dd jerry
as you know i'm in chris
christie chaos broadcast all the time so
if you still watch his broadcast you see
dtt jerry
so titty jerry was born
as
city
jerry as a tt that's his sex chris gave
me this name d.d jeff since then i just
been growing up as ctjre
right you um and you also
um you also are my youngest daughter's
uh godmother yes yes um um
the auntie and uncle of my nieces
jess
violet dalala my children and tristan my
my third daughter chris kids
and also your jasmine the mother of my
children's you're her biological uncle
and godfather godfather yes a lot of
people will ask me how how did you find
these jared said i didn't fight t.j
jerry tt jerry found me yeah okay
through the open legs of his of his
niece
um and uh
uh oh spaghetti or now ttj is wearing a
sweatshirt um that is from unb home
loans they are very uh they're i did a
show for them out in the movie theater
in levittown yeah so they are republican
and it's nice to see it's i'm sorry
they're very happy that you're wearing
their sweatshirt they're very supportive
of you every time i come on i'm always
wearing something on yours or jazz i
know everybody jasmine's always wearing
my stuff too
um
now what we do here in hey babe is
number one we don't we try not to curse
we try to keep it all clean and we try
to just stay in the box now the first
door i want to talk to you about is
there was an elderly florida man accused
of masturbating on a flight from newark
to boston thoughts masturbating on who
number one
he was just masturbating or who i think
he was just debating on i think there
was turbulence he got a little nervous
and i think he started your stroke and
then
by him masturbating that's the only way
he could have conjoined his nerve or
something like here's his name donald
edward donald edward robertson he's 76.
he was busted at boston's logan
international airport after he allegedly
flashed its genitals to a 21-year-old
female passenger
and grabbed her thigh without consent oh
can't do that right you can do that he's
going to jail now you think he is
where's the wheel he's getting our
charges where's the weirdest place you
masturbated
don't we just spot i masturbate it yeah
let me see that was a whole bunch
what's one can you can you give us can
you round it you know maybe top two top
three um
well i think in the beach under the
blanket chris your daughter's right
behind you
can you please go by the pool jerry's
telling his stories again you're a tt
sorry where'd you say i think under the
blanket in the beach
okay what happened at the beach that was
just uh no but i was with somebody i
know i know
no i'm talking about a loan this guy was
alone on a flight alone while my private
place at home i really never masturbate
industries well let me ask you this
we'll be on a flight we'll be on a
flight to puerto rico this weekend is
there any chance you're you're you're
not going to flash your genitals to
anyone right see somebody masturbating
you're going to be in a lot of trouble
you're going to well oh also
i want to give again for the people that
may not know i want to give a
congratulations to tt jerry she for the
first time she's 18 years old is off
parole
off state parolin off federal parole
you are
you just cannot masturbate on a plane i
would never do that good have you
mastered any anywhere weird i'm not
talking about masturbation
okay the first time i ever actually
masturbated and felt the sensation i
didn't you know i didn't have any any um
spermicide or anything like that but the
first sensation i ever i ever felt was
in the back of my sixth grade classroom
um i rubbed my penis and balls on the
bottom of my desk and felt a a nice
sensation shout out sister on mary r.i.p
um you r.i.p to you um i masturbate in
the back of her class um i by humping
the the bottom part of my desk i
remember one kid from queens i knew used
to jerk off like in traffic
yeah and training people really jerk off
in the car that yeah
yeah a lot of people jump off any
anywhere anywhere i don't understand
that that's crazy
it is sick tt but you know what listen
there's a lot of people do crazy stuff
yeah as long as they don't really expose
themselves out there to everybody they
they feel like they're doing it private
they feel like if they do it in the car
it's it's crazy to me that's crazy now
let me ask you this sherry you're gonna
go back to your homeland to puerto rico
for the first time in a long time as a
free woman i was three years old i never
been to parties were you born in puerto
rico i was born in puerto rico i came
here when i was three years old because
sal is also half salon is puerto rican
as well he's half yeah do we have a big
puerto rican fan base yolanda vega is
puerto rican who's a big fan of the show
you know jolanda vega with the new york
lottery coach
lotto from the lotto yeah she's puerto
rican um now are you are you what are
you most excited about um girl anymore
she's not the lotto girl anymore who are
what are you most excited to see in
puerto rico um i think i'll cry once i
see puerto rico the line cause the first
thing's gonna come to my mind is my mom
your mom who passed away
right that's because she was born in
puerto rico yeah yeah yeah but we're
going to the part of someone right we're
going to go to san juan as that's where
they got that right there that's the the
satellite that that big satellite right
they have a satellite oh
that's where you guys are from that's
what's
going
on
you're from there not for my deceiver
yes that's what's going on
so how is she from a different place
it's close to paul's she's crazy
was the name of the car company in the
neighborhood i grew up in shout out
richwood queen's rc but car company yeah
i threw up in one of your guys car once
and you charged me 50 bucks
um
yeah it's still a colony puerto rico is
like an extension of the united states
you don't even need a passport we're
going to go over there
yeah
good thing about it let me ask you the
columbia christopher columbus
yes
no i can't go to i can't even no
questions to arrive he was the first guy
to arrive to puerto rico that's what
they say well no i mean the puerto rican
island was inhabited by the tainos
um um
we're indian well that considers us
indian are you yeah wow i say native
american
now what do you think of what what do
you think of of um
[Music]
robots coming robots are starting to
make a big comeback uh or robots i mean
are starting to really come out um as
like gonna be a thing in society do you
think they'll be puerto rican robots
of course there'll be puerto rican
boardwalks they're like any kind of
other what do you think a puerto rican
robot would be like robot's been out for
forever we just haven't
really got into really searching got
into it like it is now there's a lot of
um
electronic things that work like robots
the vibe can clean up for the floor
that's like yo roomba
imagine imagine the world got taken over
by roombas
just everyone just gets sucked up um
there's they have slime robots that can
operate in your body um they have all
different kinds but what did you think
what would a puerto rican robot be like
a freak
a freak robot puerto rican robot
now
how do you feel jerry is there a sense
of um fear
now that you're off parole for the first
time since you're 18 is there a sense of
like oh my god what if i make another
mistake i never want to go back or how
do you feel oh no i feel confidence i
feel i feel with a lot of energy i feel
i think i'm i've been thinking positive
no negative thoughts been going through
my mind
you've been feeding the good wolf
yeah i've been doing everything right so
i'm not i'm not free i'm excited excited
it's like living a new life like i'm
finally living my life right
i love it without being on parole or
nothing being free willing to do
anything i want to do the right way and
not mess up
you know and i i feel great you feel
good yeah i feel like i'm starting to
live yeah at my oldest age because i'm
already about 57
and i feel like that's when i'm starting
to live
57 but we just found out no colon cancer
you got a colonoscopy and you are clean
clean clean got it
clean double probation double probation
yep so she's good double double
now br i like by the way i like you know
a fashion statement if you guys are are
aren't watching this tt jerry has made a
nice fashion statement for the fellas
and ladies out there she's tied the
strings of her sweatshirt around her
neck like a choker so that's something
you guys can do that's a little sexy
benati is taking a peek saying maybe
this is new fashion idea uh that's an
idea so um britney spears
she says she's pregnant after her
conservative conservatorship ends how
old is she now how old how old i think
she's being i would say 40. i think
she's like 46. no she's younger than
that i would say late 30s early 40s i
guess
she's 40.
four zero okay december 2nd 1981
um while she was in a conservatorship
with her uh with her dad meaning her dad
uh handled all her finances wouldn't let
her out of the house and soon
didn't she put her
something like that she did so they're
saying that's why this is interesting
because as soon as the conservatorship
ended conservatorship however you say it
ended she immediately went and got
pregnant so they're thinking that you
know um
i don't know like she was just out there
she just wanted
hey baby
her uh her fiance or her boyfriend is
jacked he's 28.
he's 28 years old there's something
interesting going on in the universe
this is the same age as pete and kim
so interesting so is britney spears and
her boyfriend sam ashkari are the same
age as kim kardashian and p davidson
interesting interesting delilah no no
we're doing a show in here not
we need our own studio we just i gotta
get our own studio yes
yeah yeah you really want to get into it
yeah that's good at early age because
you just started learning growing up
learning so much yeah no sh i wish she
knew spanish
let me tell you something about she's
being 40 and she has a guy named 27 or
two what are we gonna do
i mean i feel like
i like a young guy okay like not not
young like 18 or 19 but like in his late
twenties
because he makes me feel young right he
makes me feel younger you know and i he
doesn't make me feel oh me being with a
younger dude
it makes me feel younger and so you like
that you'll want to do a lot of things
that young people do so what is it that
old dudes do that's so boring and
especially there's a lot of um um
young guys that like older women
you know they said because they got more
experience and yeah well i know like
when i was in 18 when i was 17 18 19
years old i would always look for women
that had kids because i'd be like you
know they've
yeah
but that's a young man where's people
criticizing oh that could be your son
you could be his grandmother
shut up exactly enjoy that i think jerry
now let me ask you a question because
you logan is not a minor
right yeah now let me ask you a question
let me ask you a question you now
because you know you're a little bit
older you're wiser
you've been through a lot you know um
and and i wish sal was here because you
know we we're both you know uh uh
looking you know we we both have never
experienced this but you were married
you were married um and you got married
in prison yeah and just take us through
the ceremony
i got married a couple of times i got
married like five times in prison but i
only got married married one time like i
made my own wedding gown and everything
with the white sheets they give you
and present oh look something like this
there you go
yeah but they got wedding guns and
everything i mean you made yours out of
prison cheats
yeah it started as a joke it started as
a joke i told my man his name was
bombillo he was dominican shut up bambio
shut up yo wherever you are yes i'm
talking about you
how do you spell that bumbio bombillo
b-o-m-b-i
bomba
why was he in there he was in there for
um gun um um
possession weapon possession of a weapon
okay so not that big of a deal no not
because when i was in that prison in
fiscal that's a medium like when you
enter max doing big time but like when
you're ready to go home like you got two
years or less they'll transfer you to a
medium did you were you ever in a
maximum yeah that's how i did all my
time in the max and then there's some
big boys up there whoa oh that's how i
seen sun and sand that's how i seen all
these guys so take us through bambi oh
so how was that
your man he belonged to the trinidad to
that that
uh
or yeah again of trinidad dominican
but all these people dominic and the
trinity that they were they loved me so
much they had so much respect for me
because every time they used to go into
war or
or fight with other people like the
bloods and things like that i always
used to be next to them and i always
used to go at it with them right you
know i was the only one um transgender
that always used to be
behind them and anything went down i was
with them right you know so that's why
they had so much resp respect for me and
they loved me so much that when they
found out that bambi joe was messing
around with me
they pulled him to the side they told
him you got 30 days to make up your mind
either you want to be with him or or are
you going to
get out of being one of us or are you
going to stop messing around with him
one of the other 30 days to decide you
decide to stay with me it's it's like
it's like the new notebook yeah so he
did it when was the moment he told you
that he was gonna stay with you and not
the gang
i mean like after like we were together
like for two months no but do you
remember the moment he came in the room
and said what happened
oh
no i don't really remember but
it was can you describe him what was he
like he was struggling he was thin like
with a beer okay
teeth
he was like my colored skin short curly
hair now was he married with children on
the outside no okay no he wasn't married
with nobody outside and everything so we
started talking and everything we got
together and what what was like an
average date with him what would you
guys do that was so how did you guys
bond over what in prison
um we used to work in a mess hall
so we used to both work in the kitchen
and mess and we used to go behind the
boxes and everything you know and do a
thing go to
there's a lot of places where you could
do things you could get away in prison
where you could go and hide and do your
[ __ ] and everything now what what did
you
when you guys were together what was
your happiest moment what would give us
the happiest moment in the relationship
and the saddest moment
the saddest moment was let's start happy
let's feed the good wolf first the most
happiest day was when i told him um babe
i want to get married let's get married
he goes are you crazy are you playing
around well get married how are we going
to get married i said yeah let's get
married all right all this and that's so
i went i started making a wedding dress
with my sheets and everything
and i told them we get to marry and the
sergeants lieutenant i already spoke to
them they knew about it and they said it
was okay
they loved me lieutenants and officers
and everything then they had my respect
they said miranda you run [ __ ] here
right they used to tell me that when i
was in fish skill they said you run [ __ ]
here miranda whatever you want to do
you're the best do what you want to do
whatever makes you happy so i made my
wedding dress and everything i told him
that's what i was going to do and i told
bombidio to get dressed and everything
and he did would have been beautiful
he just had some greens the greens that
you wear from prison the greens and a
white shirt right and then we walked in
the aisle no we set it up and everything
i told my girlfriends the other
transgenders and
all the other there were your
bridesmaids yeah they were all there
together they all had
and everything
and it was something like
amazing because once they see me coming
out the doors
at my my gallery going out to the yard
they see me dressed up but a lot of
people didn't know that was going to go
on that was happening so but when they
saw me they got surprised i said what
the
wow
how is going on here and i said oh [ __ ]
yo jayla was getting married
everybody started screaming and
everything then they got this other guy
on the bible and everything amazing
now how long how long did that marriage
last that marriage lasts like two years
whoa that's pretty significant yeah but
then he got transferred it's uh that's
what i was going to ask you so
technically you're still married to him
if ben b
that's prison mary it's not it's not
like it's all marriage it sounded pretty
real to me i had a rape i don't know
what the hell is that what was the ring
made out of i have five no it was a gold
ring where did he get it he had it on he
had it on oh okay so it wasn't like his
butt or anything no he had it on
so he put that ring on i have a few
questions
yeah um was there vows
yeah there were a lot of times there was
somebody that read the bible and
everything
and everything while i accept them as my
husband i said yes i do
and all that we kiss at the end and all
that they threw us rice
and everything then we just started
walking around the whole y'all holding
hands and what'd you do for your
honeymoon
um what we used to do every day
did you go chicochi would you allow
yeah yeah shout out to that officer yes
and um
every time he used to come on he knew
that was my husband so he said miranda
come here you want to go into the room
with him for the night what am i my chef
and i said sure why not and he i used to
have a one-man room because i was a
transgender so they had me separated
with only oh i couldn't be in a room
with nobody else so i only had one man
room
so he said i'm gonna let bambi yo you
know go in there with you and spend the
night until it's time for me to go home
then i'll let you know don't go in the
door knock on the door and you got to
get out did you guys ever get into a big
fight about it yeah we used to fight so
much
time
all the time what would bamboo i'll do
my guys in prison that knew me and every
time a guy used to come and try to talk
to me i said yo don't [ __ ] with this one
that one will beat the [ __ ] out of you
and they're very similar to your niece
yeah
a whole bunch of them what the what's
this one oh yeah i found some just
that's a robot dog this is bambio's gift
to you it looks like bombillo too
with a lightbow on the top there's uh
there's um
there's so i'm sorry for cutting you off
but yeah we had a good time i i had a
good life in prison i can complain but
not so much that you would go back no
not so much that i would go back but
since i was there i had to do my best i
had to you know live my life what was
your favorite moment no uh memory with
bambino
not bad beano
us sitting together all the time
watching the soap operas the spanish
soap operas we we were hooked to that we
always used to go out to the yard and
sit together for your clothes holding
hands or i used to sit on his lap and
watch the soap operas now something
that's timely that's happening because
this you know is today you know it's
coming out in a couple days but there
was a terrorist attack today we believe
what they think on the new york city
subway system at the 36th street stop in
brooklyn on fourth avenue coincidentally
tt jerry's subway stop and what you said
to me was when you're watching the news
unfold you said you thought you wished
that you were there you wanted to be
there on that train i mean yeah just to
see what was going on and everything and
if i could have cashed the dude they did
that i would go after him and i would
have tried to trap him right you know
that would have been amazing because
then they would have seen that city
jerry did that oh my god did they jerry
the hero
all over
i would have been all over the news i
always that woman i always every time
something like that happens i always
wish that i was around because i would
put a stop to it if i could like a guy's
trying to scoring around stopping people
in time squaring my hat and
i won't be afraid to go up to the guy
and so what would be your catchphrase
what would you say to them yeah like
nothing i would just jump them yeah
i've been through so much in prison i
have gotten stabbed so many times and
everything that i'm not afraid were you
ever the hero in prison did you save
somebody else
yeah i did you saved the life let's hear
a hero's story
from getting
involved in the in the cutting and
everything why what what happened how
did you stop it did you just say sit
down and say everyone take a deep breath
no
i seen what was going down and i jumped
the guy i jumped the guy and everything
and the officer was gonna butt in and he
see when i
jumped to do instead of the officer
going jump him i jumped the duke because
he had a while you think do you think
that the guy that you jumped maybe
thought the officer was on him because
he felt a baton on his back but it
wasn't
then that's why that's why when i used
to go to different different prisons my
name used to ring bells with their
offices and and i travel like from
offices to offices and travel to
different prisons well listen cause i
knew miranda who miranda was already
when i used to get there well your name
though in the prison system was known as
jlo
you were known as jlo so now jlo is
getting married to ben affleck she's
re-engaged yeah she got engaged too bad
what do you think about one thing i
think that's great i think that's great
because she always loved that man she
always loved that man when she watched
she was with rodriguez right what's her
name
is it is it ben affleck a-rod or mark
anthony oh casper
casper
casper the ghost she was with the dancer
oh yeah captain how did you met the
friendly ghost no
his name was caspar wasn't his name
casper it might have been casper oh
they're this one yeah go up a little
open tough daddy yeah
i think that's a gun charge for him
probably in a club 440 i think it was a
40 yeah a club 40 or a club um but you
think jlo you think you think um uh
that's him right there that's casper
smart that's the other one up that one
right that's casper now do you think
he's cute yeah okay he's like he's all
right
she was no she was yeah yeah she i think
she just did a couple months with drake
yeah she probably just laid him she
probably just laid him for a couple of
days he has a line about
in a chorus about how j.lo changed her
number
like he lost her number she just ghosted
him
oh wow look at that this is beautiful
good for j.lo right i don't know i i
feel like her guys are all kind of doofy
i mean i thought he was more handsome
well how many men she had already she
had like six right six oh husbands i
don't know about husbands no not a
husband she only married judgement
people have boyfriends and girlfriends
she married mark anthony she also
married her first boyfriend which was he
was what uh uh what was he
what was her first husband's name um
no i wasn't mark anthony
her first husband he was young she's got
three rings
spanish she got she's like lebron
he was um um he might have more i think
yeah
yeah yeah him
that was her first husband she only has
kids i think with mark yeah just one
long time stimpy from wren and stimpy
yeah um
chris judd is another guy
yeah you forget about all these guys
i mean look at this i mean i'm
i think she makes a good couple with ben
affleck though you think so yeah you
been out you like ben affleck even mark
anthony but
they were both puerto rican people have
told me i look i look like ben affleck
at times or ben stiller
depends which way the light hits me
there he goes
that's the way the light hits you
yeah then after wow what uh
he looks there where over there in that
pitch
he drinks a lot he likes to have a few
which hey what can you do who doesn't
right
what age do you consider somebody old
at what age i consider somebody oh when
they can't get out of bed anymore when
they can't wipe their ass anymore so
it's not a it's not a number thing for
you no you could be 75 and now and be
younger
and do everything young people do i
don't consider nobody oh and so they
really really am bad they can't do
nothing for themselves but as long as
you could get up and walk for me i see
you still young what's the longest ever
what's the longest you ever walked in
high heels
the longest i walked why i walked a lot
when i used to get dressed all the time
like few years back i used to dress up
like a girl every day every day and i
used to walk all day with you and they
never hurt your feet no
yeah because you have because you cause
what size high heel are you here
what size high heel are you
i wear size six inches seven inches no
what size is the shoe though if people
want to send you high heels nine and a
half nine and a half to go
if you got any good shoes
yep that's what it is she put this
there's a woman with her butt and she's
she suffered uh you could tell she got a
lot of hope a sexually transmitted
allergic reaction to nuts this girl so
so there's a girl that's claiming that
she got an std from nuts
um
so what can you do um yeah we never said
that i think uh the amazon warehouse on
staten island is the only one to
unionize in the country yeah the dude
how funny is that that if if there's
going to be a union it's stan island
did you heard about um uh um will smith
there banned him for 10 years from that
yeah yep i heard that and oh dummy
shoves four pound dumbbell and anus need
what can we click on that he put that up
his butt
he put a dumbbell in his anus i guess he
just you know
he wanted
he really loved that steel up his butt
there it goes in prison what was the
weirdest thing people were putting up
their butts
um
weapons
right mostly drugs
yeah you put a weapon that's all it is
yeah that's what people do like they
used to put like scalpels and everything
up scalpels why would they put a scalpel
in their butt but they used to put black
tape but that electric tape oh my god
but why just to smuggle it from one side
to the other just to put it up just in
case they need to protect themselves or
without dissecting things
the officers won't catch them
was it for biology class
[Music]
what if the tape rolls the other way oh
man
they're taking a chat they used to put
them in their mouths too just blazed
on their mouths so there's this guy
um he put um crap but listen let me tell
you something people do weird things
no brazilian people do crazy stuff shout
out brazil when i um when i was a
physical therapist there was a man who
came in with excruciating back pain and
we couldn't reproduce his pain as a
physical therapist we couldn't figure
out where this back pain was coming from
so finally they went to send them for an
x-ray which is in the same building and
my boss called me goes chris come here
and he shows me the x-ray there was uh
one of his children's um
uh toys was in his anal cavity i think
it was a matchbox car or some type of
toy like little toy was up his butt and
the guy was like he didn't know how it
got there
that's what he said he was like i don't
know well yeah who knows delilah can you
go inside please baby
okay just pick up the garbage quick
delilah you're do you want to be a
garbage man or do you want to be a
garbage woman when you grow up
she said ill
um go ahead mama now what do you think
of lizzo delilah please shut the door
oh my lord have mercy on the zone what
do you think
what do you think of that jerry is that
good for you bad for you how do you like
that that [ __ ] will kill me that would
kill you right if a man had an [ __ ]
imagine putting your face right between
that that [ __ ] will kill me
she's now promoting her new shapewear so
she's a promo she has like shapewear
like well i give it to her though i give
it to her
because she's not ashamed to show her
body
why should you be ashamed be confident
of yourself be real you know
this is me you love me you gotta love me
uh-uh you have to love yourself yeah no
matter what how you look always be you
be yourself be feel good about your body
feel good about yourself yeah i think i
i agree i to be honest with you v if you
can use the company card i'd like to get
a pair of these pants
i want to get a paper puerto rico
yeah that's what we're going to do is
we're going to get those which by the
way april 22nd doing a show in san juan
puerto rico christy
wikis i just told chris to come out and
say chrissy chacon
because it is the big fan can you google
eating chalcone how do you like that
she was the number one fan in puerto
rico for so many years it is no not
that's eddie katie shakon is uh
he's a singer
sings um
he used to sing his chapter famous song
she was almost famous
she was the most famous number one woman
in puerto rico she's from san juan
puerto rico she's from san juan that's
why when you get on stage when you get
on stage and you say
chrissy choco everybody's going to go
berserk let's go
and say her nickname was
puerto rico
i love it uh and i want you to play that
song when you go on stage um of heart
assault they're going to go but they're
going to go crazy
[Music]
what would be your advice kim kardashian
called kanye west in tears after a
six-year-old saw a joke about her sex
tape so what would you tell
basically kim kardashian six-year-old
saw her sex tape um and you know how do
you explain that to the kid if that was
you if
your child sees your sex tape how are
you gonna talk to them about that
i mean i would tell them you know
it was just some
[Music]
it was just a a a playful thing that we
were doing you know it was only just a
joke don't pay no mind to that you know
then they might do sex tapes as a joke
oh yeah it's true
right uh i i don't know how to explain
that to them i was saying listen baby
it's something that you shouldn't be
seeing
and it's something that all um grown-up
people do
right you know that's how you came to
this world you know and
i will explain to them i tell them the
truth
since you've already seen the tape well
you know what else could you tell well
the the truth is now tt we're growing up
in a world you know i have little kids a
lot of listeners have little kids who
are growing up in a world now where
there's just a lot of sex tapes floating
around it's it's a thing it's a thing
that's gonna happen it's it it's it's
actually kim kardashian was one of the
first but it's a thing that's just gonna
happen and very way very well may hit
you know but wait a minute it was a girl
they seen this or it was their child her
son kim kardashian's son was playing
video games online and he said and the
tape was sent the sex tape was sent to
him by somebody else online well i feel
like i just hope it wasn't my stepson i
feel like all our moms had sex tapes no
anyone who was past the 80s probably has
a sex tape
i mean i tell them that's part of life
baby you know it's like when you grow up
you will understand more a sex tape in
the 80s was tough to you'd have to get
these lights in stan can't like you'd
really have to do it like you can't say
like home camcorders
that's a funny sex tape there's a home
camcorder sexy that has to be a thing
you know me i like learning new
languages sal speaks 25 different
languages he's that's why he's not here
today he's on a mission
uh just speaking a thousand different
languages um 15-minute lessons make it
the perfect way to to learn a new
language on the go other language
learning apps use ai for their lesson
plans but not babble baby
what babel does what babel does is they
have
all these language learning experts and
they got them together and they created
this app everybody else is using
technology not them they're using just
old they're using known as cooking and
it's the best way to do it babel speech
recognition technology helps you improve
your pronunciation and accent there are
a million ways to learn with babel in
addition to lessons you can access
podcast games videos stories and even
live classes right now i'm gonna i want
you to save up i'm gonna choose i want
you to save up to 60
off your subscription all you have to do
is go to babel.com
hey babe that's b-a-b-b-e-l dot com
slash hey babe 60 off your subscription
babble language learning for life as
always this podcast is sponsored by
better help now you know me i use better
help sally babes uses better help we
love it um it literally you know there's
a lot of things like you know when
you're stressed out you may not even
realize you're stressed it's like a
daily thing how do you feel about it
what stresses you out are you eating
more are you eating less are you
sleeping more you're sleeping less all
this stuff is stress and better help are
the stress people they help with the
stress they get you get uh counselors to
come in and talk to you and the best
part about it is is it's all done online
you don't have to go anywhere you don't
have to leave the house nobody has to
know but you and your counselor what's
going on it is a customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy
and give it a try and see if online
therapy can help blow your stress stress
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and hey babe listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
hey babe that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash hey babe my protein shake
was blocking it that woman that uh um um
um
you just were talking about um um
the [ __ ] woman
woman with the big mouth woman but the
[ __ ] woman that's [ __ ] on the under
on the box oh yes the the [ __ ] queen the
sheep from
i was laughing when that came when you
were talking about them what happened
tell us what happened
in sixth grade which hey it happens
which i did it was i was descending
it was on december it was on december
and i was sitting all the way in the
back of the class
and i thought i had to take a mean [ __ ]
you know when you think you got to take
a bad [ __ ] you can't hold it no more and
it's like coming out
and it just finally comes out you're
like oh my god i don't know what you're
talking about and i [ __ ] it but that was
a lot of [ __ ]
and it started stinking everybody like
oh my god yo it stinks in here and you
were pretending you were good yeah i'll
pretend oh my god i'm like oh my gosh
stinks like [ __ ] everybody opening the
windows and everything so people all the
students started getting up and the
teacher opened the door they all started
going out to the hallway and i was the
only one that's still sitting in the
chair in the back right of course
because i was the one that [ __ ] it
oh my god what was that for then i had
to get up the [ __ ] rolling down my pants
i could have feel that [ __ ] rolling down
my mind what did you have on jeans
i don't remember what i had no you
probably did you have on corduroy pants
yeah something like that
yeah that's why because you want to
dress up like almost
now but way back that's what we used to
wear like a lot of portals [ __ ]
yourself in the corner that's not funny
the polyester pens right so how did it
get resolved what happened afterwards
i had to get up they called my mom and
everything i lived right across the
street and they sent me home i was in
the sixth grade but what happened after
that then everybody started calling me
shitty
that was my name from now on every time
i used to go back to school they used to
say hey shitty they go shitty shitty and
to this day i told you i'd be bumping
into some people that were in my class
that day and they still call me shitty
do you think that was the moment where
you decided i'm going to go transgender
no
look here's my other nine-month-old
daughter she's trying to she's did
no no
no rihanna i see not holding a baby
yes to a baby girl no no no yeah
yeah i seen a hole in the girl a little
baby in her arms
not too long ago
look at violet loves to put her nose and
lips on the glass that's just squishes
her face
she's so beautiful i think rihanna might
be like look look at her look at her
look at her
my kid my kid's in the background
smushing her face up against the glass
that's another one that's gonna be on
the broadcast that wants to do
everything you do oh she's ready to
podcast yeah violet's gonna she's
already started once so have you had the
podcast talk with your kids yet i've
told well that's the interesting thing
is because kim kardashian's
six-year-old saw her sex tape and my
six-year-old's gonna see my podcast i'd
rather a sex tape yeah
and i'm gonna have to explain to her why
i've said and done the things i've said
and done on the podcast um while holding
her hey how did we hey rihanna got in
vogue magazine i'm supposed to be in
vogue magazine she is so beautiful she
might be the most beautiful pregnant
woman like i think rihanna i'm i'm ready
to go on record i think i think
rihanna's the most beautiful like
celebrity
i think so i agree she's so gorgeous and
and like it looks like almost i think
she's naturally beautiful no i don't
think she has any plastic surgery i
think this is what she looks like
old photographers like alicia keys at
least she kisses me
is beautiful yeah i think i think no
makeup no nothing what do you think
about her and asap rocky as a couple do
you know who asap rocky is a rapper
that's her that's her is it her husband
he's younger than her we're together i
think he's a little younger
younger than him
she's technically a few eight months
older how old is rihanna and asap are
they even 30 yet they're like 33 they're
both 33. she's just a few months older
and you know what they have like a very
quiet relationship like yeah they'll be
on the low-key like i don't think
rihanna even is out there like rihanna's
made a billion dollars already played
his girlfriend in a music video eight
years ago like it seems like they kind
of and they've been together for all
that time i don't know i know drake was
upset because drake made a move on her
at an award show because she's not even
in the limelight anymore because she's
1.7 billion dollars what does she have
to do she does drake used to date
actually yeah drake right now
and then she um started getting with him
in the pandemic i think just before the
pandemic that they were yeah
she started dating um um um
drake right after um um i think they all
date each other for a year they dated
it's eight years old the music video
where they're like making out
interesting right after chris brown she
started dating um um um drake that was
guys
that had something huge um chris brown
and drake had a fight or something in
the club because of ah some [ __ ] was
going on chris brown i mean yeah chris
brown beat her i remember when he beat
her off of course of course
i feel like a lot of people don't even
care for something i know well it would
happen so long ago but that's but that's
the thing with celebrity is like you do
something and it's the worst time and
then it just time goes by and nobody
cares um it's what it is she's the
second rihanna is the second richest
woman in entertainment after oprah good
for you rihanna she is can you donate to
the patriots 1.7 billion yeah yeah oh
there goes her man right over there asap
rocky now asap rocky is is your
physically is your type of guy yes you
like an eagle you're a guy you'd like if
you're a hey listener out there
baby if you're hearing this i'm here
forget about rihanna
huh that could be your new rihanna it's
teaching jerry's rihanna i'll be rihanna
for you
i'll be rihanna honestly i'm gonna tell
my kids i like tt jerry what's wrong
kim kardashian is beautiful as well oh
yeah yeah so
look at liza look at that body so are
you tt look at that
are you sure that that plane could hold
her though oh god
at that please get that for the show
wow
good for you
chris the first time
we should wear these i love her i love
her she has no shame in her is this the
prize for the special
look at that good for you lizzo i love
her i like her i like her too that
should be a goal i want tt to fly
private tt can fly well i mean she could
don't they have those private jets now
where like you can share it's like an
uber for private jets really i think so
how much they cause
i mean they cost money but obviously not
as much as just renting it yeah go go
private jet uber yeah uber jets no i'm
telling you dude jetting made simple
yeah
they got uber jets
yeah there you go yeah go to [ __ ]
salt flat texas put
four
let's see oh god now you have to put in
all the info just google google how much
to uberjet
roughly is there an uber for private
jets
yeah
there you go
what
is that
the app the app cost seven thousand
dollars just having the app yeah
if the membership
oh it's like the soho house
wow
i'm listening the average ticket costs
twenty thousand those who become members
for seven thousand a year can get free
or discounted empty leg flights which
travel empty when a plane returns to its
home base after dropping off passengers
the average jet smarter member is tech
savvy aged between 25 and 15 earns at
least a million a year
wow interesting some of the most popular
routes include the golden triangle
between miami new york and la but almost
anything is possible jetsmarter once
received a request to transport a ton of
gold between south america and europe
very very very very very very very
interesting that they had now of ubers
what is the cheapest way to fly private
go down
with a hundred dollar monthly membership
fee in one-way flight starting at 446
setjet is one of the most affordable
private air travel options on the market
what
wow
look at that
it's that like
yeah
jet jet asap look at all these guys if
you're out there you can fly in a
private jet i mean we can get this tt
far how much
well i'd have to we'd have to pay the
membership
uh uh from new york city to miami on
blade one starts at 24.50 per leg i mean
that's expensive of course but it's not
insane
24.50 per person look at the weird yeah
the future's gonna be real weird with
the uber model a lot of money yeah what
is blade it's like a helicopter and a
plane i think they have planes now let's
see what they have i think schultz did
this last week yeah he did
but from new york to miami on blade no
no not in the helicopter no i know i
think it's like a different kind of
thing
yeah i don't know
blade
see helicopters scare me because if
someone comes to the propeller you're
going to fall there's me and tt went up
in the helicopter this year you weren't
i feel that no i wasn't scared at first
i was i ain't going to lie yeah at first
i was but i got i got you see tt was so
quiet we went from the hanger to right
next to it was like
it's happening yeah but then i got used
to i got a little bit loose decided
started putting one leg out at a time
and how did you feel mean tt took the
helicopter right around manhattan that's
on foreign i would love to do it again
i would like to go like you me jazz
on a on a helicopter yeah you don't care
about a private plane you like the
helicopter i mean yeah no she's gonna go
on a private plane but i'm talking about
just to go around the city and
everything i would like to go like all
of us
not nobody else like that we don't know
remember we should go with other
let's go have a good time i want to do
it at night yeah i know i do want to go
ahead
yeah i want to um i i i do want to go on
a private plane i had one opportunity to
do it and i chickened out because i feel
like you always hear about private plans
i see you skip that helicopter right
what's wrong you you got you don't like
me no i hadn't i had to do i had to um i
was uh working out yeah right i had to
do something yeah you're are you scared
to get on a helicopter open door huh i
know the only i'm the only pla i just i
like flying jet blue if jetblue made a
helicopter you know what i would like to
do i would like to jump out of a
building
watch okay
yeah why i would like to jump out of a
building like at least six stories high
like bungee jump out of a building no
just jump
and where would you
jump to see uh and land on my feet do
you think if you watch like
they said that your legs will crack and
break and they will go up
like
and you'll get stabbed you'll get killed
by your leg bones like when you land on
your leg if it's so high that your leg
bones and everything were cracking it
would sunk into your body
no i i think if you if you if you fell
i think if you fell from a height of six
stories you'd break the bones in your
legs but that won't break your bone and
they will go like no stuck into your
body i don't think so i don't think so
um
i think that six fours is too high
though if you want to experience it i
think you've jumped maybe jump out of
the first floor i jumped like a third
floor one time when i was in boston
although a woman did survive yes a
plunger more than 5 000 feet after a
parachute fail so anything is possible
anything is possible yeah oh and fell
straight i jumped i jumped out of the
three uh three story building in boston
and when i was when i was young i was
like i was like 14. why'd you jump out
of a building there was snow that was
big pile of snow about this high so we
jump from the from the third floor into
the pile of snow did you get hurt no
because we were jumping in the pile of
snow look at this guy he's about to jump
off a roof do you ever see the people do
park i would love to do all that parkour
is scary man i don't get how you get
good at it where do you practice just
like uh i don't know in france somewhere
where does an open mic parkour person
did you just see that jump
look at that look at how scary if you
missed that [ __ ] oh my god dude parkour
is just full
full 100 i would love to do all that
like jump from one building to another
building
right yeah i like all that you know you
can't be all that dangerous you can't be
an insecure person and do this no that's
all that's what i'm saying it's 100
confidence parkour yeah 100
like you'll never see larry david do
parkour no chance
no chance i mean look at look at the
talent i just be worried i just feel
like i'd sprained my ankle and fall off
a roof
they're just not scared at all they've
done this
they're confident whoa
oh okay
no no no no no no they have zero
absolute
zero
is that australia no that building this
is hong kong oh that's hong kong or did
you see them just slide open that thing
that was sick dude
but you know what it'd be great this
video was all chinese people should this
be the promo for this special
she's hired parkour people well did you
see that guy just slide this down man
they're finesse these kids
these kids don't give a [ __ ]
i mean there's a lot of weird [ __ ] that
people to be doing a lot there's so many
things people be doing some crazy stuff
wow this video is sick like i would like
i would love to jump off the bridge
on a bridge did you see somebody got
arrested climbing the bridge a couple
mornings ago
climbing the varrazano bridge climbing
the brooklyn bridge let me find it what
were they they were climbing the bridge
somebody got arrested when they tried to
climb the the brooklyn bridge up but
that was a few years ago
and he took the flag remember he took
the flag from the bridge
from the brooklyn bridge i think i met
that kid in an arc out there there was a
little kid who was doing that he went
viral for it what an idiot what is this
people doing oh this is on the bridge
four days ago in the brooklyn bridge why
did he climb who were the worst are
there workers up there no the cops had
to go
oh they were also they weren't allowed
to
oh those are the cops right there yeah
why did he i guess he climbed and then
he got scared
i don't know why maybe he didn't flipped
him they stopped him that's why he
stopped he had to climb down i mean
that's why the police are on the
property to stop people from jumping how
about that guy that crossed the world
trade center from one to the other one
remember him
that you remember that chris that he
crossed the world trade center with one
of those poles how do you call those
those
tightrope walking
yes i saw this guy philly petite i saw
this documentary and i thought they were
going to do tightrope walking yesterday
at the circus that i took my family to
at the staten island wall i went to a
circle
yeah philippe petit wasn't there
shockingly
this guy here had no support at all
insane in the membrane i'm just happy he
wasn't doing that on 911.
what a coincidence
[Music]
[Music]
um can we i mean that's i mean even just
i would love to do something like that
but i gotta be tied up just for support
and i will do it title for supporter
yeah i would do that but they gotta tie
like a rope or something just in case i
fall i will bounce like like yeah but
the whole point of this is i think
though if they tie ropes to you it pulls
you out of equilibrium and i think
that's you you'll have a higher chance
of falling i think
we got to get you tired walking and we
got to do a trapeze with you
flying trap you know they have a flying
trapeze go off the side of the west side
highway yeah i don't know if you're
close to covered why don't we get tt to
do trapezoidal open we should do that
what's this it's like a flying trip
piece like you just like you're hooked
up to something you kind of do like
flips
and you just throw yourself off of what
off just like a ledge and then you're
just like you know doing spins and
you're but how hello fresh america's
number one meal kit we've been talking
about this for years i love it chefs
they know how to diversify the menu with
seasonal recipes like salmonella
and pasta primavera i love hellofresh
we've been using it we've been getting
fit as a fiddle in here and it's all
hello fresh they got the wholesome
recipes for satisfying uh for satisfying
your little palette wallet and it's
nutritious meals that you feel good with
six recipes per week to choose from
including low cal and carb conscious
options um it is awesome
i'm telling you hello fresh it saves me
time at the grocery store i'm not
ordering food i'm saving money and i
just love the way it tastes it's it and
and i feel like i can cook now because
of hello fresh because they make it so
easy and the the menu items they have
are dope and right now if you go to
hellofresh.com hey babe 16 you are going
to get 16 free meals plus three free
gifts so if you go to hellofresh.com hey
babe 16. put in the promo code hey babe
16 16 free mails and three free gifts
hello fresh americans and number one
meal kit headspace listen even if you
feel like your mind doesn't have an off
switch
and that tension is constantly traveling
through your body or you feel tired and
all that stuff then head space
is the app for you
literally however you're feeling just
try head space it's something that it
just connects me like when i get up
in the morning sometimes i feel like my
feet aren't on the ground like i'm just
all over the place headspace helps me
get my feet on the ground and gets me
centered into my body and gets my soul
right and it's so easy to use it
literally improves your mental health
and well-being like almost instantly at
least it did for me i love headspace
i've always been a big big fan i've been
using it for years um and they have a
great offer right now if you're tr if
you however you're feeling try headspace
at headspace.com
hey babe and get one month free for the
entire mindfulness library that is the
head
oh sorry
however you're feeling try headspace
right now at headspace.com
hey babe and get one month free of their
entire
mindfulness library this is the best
headspace offer available so go to
headspace.com hey babe today that's
headspace.com slash hey babe it's really
high i don't know
but where is it at where
west side highway downtown chris have
you seen these people that post
themselves at legally climb buildings in
new york um let me see let me see i've
seen a whole bunch of text from uh uh
emilio okay i seen a whole bunch of
dudes doing crazy stuff like that in
manhattan but how do they film this and
then get away with it like this kid just
started climbing the side of the
building
um
how did this kid get away with it you
know like with all the cameras there was
another one that was climbing on east
9th street in manhattan i'm 57 there's a
building that goes curved
and they called them spider-man look at
this kid and he was climbing that
building look oh there's garbage in
there people live everywhere i know i
whoa look at that
oh my god scare you that wouldn't scare
you at all not scared me oh i would love
to jump out of that building with a
parachute you know how windy it is up
there
you wouldn't be scared just standing on
the edge i'm thinking that you're gonna
are you an adrenaline junkie maybe that
you just seek out these like you know
experiences to get a rush ever since no
ever since i was a child i always loved
the heights i always loved the heist
washington heights i used to spend
i just spent my times always in the roof
and looking down like in the edge of the
roof always like that in the edge
looking down what about like roller
coasters do you like going on roller
coasters i love oh my god i love crazy
who is that
well we know it's not your parole
officer cause you off parole [ __ ] who
is it
hello
if you call me speak have not go take a
swim in the ocean
that's what it is speaking of the ocean
would you ever swim in a shark in a tank
with sharks if i i'm in a tank yeah
dude what scares you more
that being on that would you how would
you rather die would you rather fall off
a building or get eaten by a shark
i think falling off a building because
you will die in the air depends how high
is the building
but being underwater eaten by shark i
think you could feel the bites and all
that don't you think so oh you die
no no you'll feel much more pain i feel
the salt water go inside so you feel
much more pain right so dang falling
from a high burner because you just push
that's it what once you hit the ground
you got it again the woman survived
skydive skydiving with them but then
again falling from a building you could
survive and you could be in so much pain
broken so much honestly let me tell you
something and let me tell the fans
something but there's a miraculous story
about a woman who survived a skydiving
accident where her parachute did not
open and she fell five thousand feet and
she fell five thousand feet and survived
and do you want to know why she survived
because she got her booster shot
that's why and she had a mask on so
that's
and i'm going to jump over building to
see if i survive
it works it works baby i mean you
you know what it was i would not i would
not like to die drowning
right that's one thing i would not like
to do don't want to die drowning
drowning that's bad you know when you
stay without swallowing a lot of things
but you don't want to stay without air
that's come you last at least couple of
at least a minute right drowning david
blaine
did it for like 30 minutes well it
sounds like people have fought you a lot
nobody's ever choked you why doesn't
that feel like drowning i mean they had
choked me having sex that's about it but
not really choking i don't like a choke
during sex to be honest with you no i
don't like it because i choked i choked
on a jalapeno popper when i was like i
was talking
like old guys
like the guy that died when somebody
starts choking me i i screamed me mommy
i need water like the guy that i was
like a guy used to play softball with in
prison um campbell wasn't then i said
can't count um campbell's campbell that
was a campbell cam newton they choked
his his girlfriend through the neck and
stunts and sunset and oh the pretty boy
killer what was his name oh yeah yeah i
forgot what that kid's name was but he
had chopped it up yeah we used to play
um soapboard together used to play
soccer
it was a chambo
yeah i think it was the preppy prep
school killer the prep school google
prep school killer oh no i think his
name was the prep school killer preppy
robert chambers
yeah that he did 15 years and after that
he all the the families um um girl used
to come to court for them and let him
cut loose then we'll let him go
who is the chillest group of people in
prison like the murderers the robbers
who was like the coolest group was it
murderers robbers uh the was the the
gangs like what was the coolest group
overall that was just fun to be around
to fun be around was like
there has so many different kinds like
probably the spanish people you like the
spanish people yeah nice spanish people
want and they'll accept us more the
spanish people will accept us like with
no problem you know all the transgenders
other gay people there that always used
to be like welcome you know but the the
other like like the dark-colored skin
people and
especially white white guys too they
used to acceptors
puerto rican people
who didn't accept you like the muslims
always complaining right but they won't
follow them what was there meanwhile you
know what a surprise would be what you
don't is there any way to prove that
prophet muhammad this muslim was so so
gay what were their complaints about uh
you being said always talking about i
always have something to say about the
gay people
always i mean who cares if you're gay
that's why i set one of them up like i
told you that i said one of them no tell
us again hey babe we didn't think
and i and i set him up i told the muslim
um people like listen hello friends you
want to talk about homosexuals all the
time i'm gonna show you who's homosexual
who really is gay
you're talking about gay people all the
time at 12 o'clock when the lights go
off going to the showers i'm gonna be
there just open the curtain and you're
going to see who's going to be in there
with me you want to talk about
homosexuals i'm going to show you
something yeah and i set it up and when
the guy went up in the car he see one of
his people's with the kufi on and
everything why don't you blow me and
everything
he held his knees already and he got
stabbed you know he got stabbed they
stabbed him for that he got stabbed he
got kicked he got he got beat up really
bad
that's crazy you always mentioned
stabbings like did you just get used to
stabbings yeah i mean that's what really
goes on in prison another day another
stabbing look what happened in um sunset
park there it is how many people got
caught i'm shot already so far so hard
definitely too many uh too many it's
it's
so pretty who are the other kardashian
girls yeah i think the older one she is
so pretty
um yeah they're all beautiful the
kardashians are beautiful the the
mirandas are beautiful what do you think
about billy racing are they all all
haven't you noticed they're all the
conductors what do you think about
you notice they all haven't you noticed
that all the conditions that really
don't
now now they started going out with
white dudes
but before when they started all they
liked it was black guys black guys they
liked it that big dingo you know like
how come you don't like white guys i do
like white guys i do like white guys i
have one guys in prison i went out with
a few guys in prison when i were white
guys in prison yeah what was one of
their names
uh johnny was one of them i remember
johnny johnny johnny white boy we used
to call him johnny white boy why did
what did johnny white boy do to get
himself live damn we just used to talk
and i never knew i really never used to
ask these people why they're locked up
before we don't care why are white boys
annoying to date
white boys are not annoying who said
they are oh you just you don't prefer
them though
yeah i mean but you know everybody has
their taste it's not that you don't want
to date him or anything but
you prefer to be with this type of
person you know it's not that you don't
like it's not i don't like to go out
have a a boyfriend or white dwell as my
boyfriend of course i would
you know but i would prefer to be with a
dog skin guy what is the update on your
boyfriend when is he getting out he's
not getting out now right what your
boyfriend the guy that we spoke about a
couple of months ago you said your
boyfriend was getting out this year oh
this year oh i'm sorry i thought that he
wasn't getting out i thought we were
gonna hear from him already
no he gets out this year at the end of
this year no spoilers well i mean tt uh
i gotta be honest with you in puerto
rico i'm a little worried because now
that
because you're off parole
and i just don't i want to go out and
have fun with you and our family but i
just worry that you're going to have so
much fun that you might get in trouble
again i get worried about it how am i
going to get in trouble because i think
you love life so much i know nah i do
love life so much now
right before when i was doing all them
crimes and drugs and everything i didn't
love life
what i i hated life because the things
that i was doing in my life
but now all these beautiful things are
surrounded with the family united with
the family and traveling and having fun
and all this of course i love my life
now right so it's a big difference
now than before
well
i will not take this if it's drugs right
there i will not choose that over my
family well because now because now
we're not well because you have a you
have like that i would throw that to the
side well look at all your jobs you have
now look at all the jobs you have now
you're our living nanny you're my kids
godmother you're a podcast
you're what i'm a cleaning lady you're a
cleaning lady
you do so many great things yeah you
have a pot your own podcast called the
ladies of chaos which they can find on
youtube
and things that i was never doing in my
life i've been
blessed so much that i can complain now
let me ask you this would you never
complain can i ask you this would you
like to satisfy i'm happy would you guys
have wait
with the little that i got right now
don't let him talk that's what just says
are you gonna let me say something let
me get a word i want you to go
did you guys ever sit in prison and
watch the impractical jokers
yeah you did yeah wow that's a big
hidden person
who was your favorite joker
in prison um i believe it or not so wow
i think sal was the funniest
name and the other one what's his name
the tall skinny one
the tallest one um the tall skinny one
um humor
um
um i don't know
hey well i don't know name
where is he that's him right there which
one that james james james murray yeah
wow you like that you like murr there
you go well i got news burr would like
you too
um who do you think the sexiest joker is
the sexiest let me see them okay let's
go back let's see i think you got i mean
they're all they're all sexy in their
own little way right
i think um joe was joe was sexy when he
was young okay
that was sad too that looked like both
of them right brian quinn what do you
think of that
brian quinn's good friend of the show
good friend of taste buds i think he's a
hot guy no he's a fireman he's a tough
guy what do you mean he's just fine he
was a he was a farmer he's a brave tough
man he's not afraid of him and now
right there the last picture he looked
like he got a hangover
well that's beautiful baby that's
beautiful teeth they watch this all the
time they watch this a lot in prison
it's a great show and what would people
say in prison watching this and they
just love the show they they go crazy
they love the show well goodbye and um
um um um remember that other show they'd
had um which one
um um the price is right no yeah they
watched out a lot too
what happened to sauer that [ __ ]
he looked like me
open his hair like that he's wearing a
wig he's wearing a wig that's a wig
he looks so funny
yeah that sound right there with his
hair fat that he was that big
yeah no that's not sal that was sound
when he was younger yeah yeah with no
beer no that's gabriel of glaciers
that's not
that's not sal that's
that's not gabriela
um
so so yeah baby um what do you think um
what happened to them there he got beat
up
probably all stuff for the show oh uh
let me ask you tt um we appreciate you
coming on the show um would you come
back of course i would come back yeah i
love it so now that what's gonna go on
the rest of you i love being here what's
the rest of your day like the rest of my
day was today tuesday tuesday
the rest of my day i gotta go i gotta
get something for puerto rico go go buy
me a pair of sneakers for puerto rico
okay we're gonna get tt a pair of
sneakers for puerto rico i gotta go buy
me yours you get him for me i'm gonna
get him for you i'm gonna get a few
we're gonna have a nice vacation we're
gonna have a nice vacation at the end of
that vacation
at the night at the end of that vacation
friday april 22nd i will be doing a show
at laura
in san juan
i can't wait
if you're going to be in san juan or
come down and you want to meet tt and i
friday april 22nd and then this saturday
april 16th holy saturday norwalk
connecticut the wall street theater this
weekend and then april 29th we are in
bethlehem pennsylvania at the wind creek
event center chrisd comedy.com for tiki
wikis also may 7th in miami at the miami
improv christy collins.com for tiki
wiki's tt jerry we love you baby i love
you too you know i think you
really
noticed enough for nothing because you
family and i think but i think you're
one of the hottest comedian in new york
i really do think so like physically
yeah like physically and his attitude
and everything
right now
not because you're family or nothing but
really looking at it i think you're one
of the hottest next up next stop new
york legend there you go baby legend
that's it baby just yeah yeah i live in
the remodeling valley
well it really is if i would have known
him i would still say the same about him
that's the that's a beautiful thing
about utt is and and just what the
course of my life is one way or another
i was going to be in a relationship in
this family whether it was with jasmine
or you one way or
another thank you guys
thank god it wasn't with me i love you
guys this has been hey i love you too
guys thank you he's coming back next
week it might be on zoom because i'll be
in puerto rico but we will have a hey
babe with the two of us next week thank
you guys for the support hey baby i
believe the merch is up um right yeah so
where where's the hay bay merch where
can i get sal's website right now and
it's hopefully you're assuming it's on
sal's website it's gonna cut which is
salvagnocomedy.com it will be on
christycomedy.com very soon um and thank
you guys so much thank you to tt jerry
we love you
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate